[Music]
[Applause]
according there we go
I mean how's it going bros my name is be
right back
welcome to X mod dis door that's a - but
a piece I I'm real not right for - like
I don't think there's any way to be
ready for this
my first yahoo precise honorable for
Silla sorry kid Oh Oh brah
and it'll choke down cupcakes all right
left that weapon and something I've been
left kidding
where's my drink all right here we go X
more this this is supposed to be scarier
than the first phone you know hear them
first well that's impossible
anyway the horse of exposed is swept
across the earth a plague on like
anything humanity had ever encountered
in their final stand a handful of
mankind's last survivor stood their
ground the find of their inevitable fate
and in those last moment as death took
those brave souls a stranger passing in
the distance put his pants plans in
motions okay where is your job now I
don't even know anymore even odds I
would say is in the church this is a
band this all leads inside I hope to get
to beyond reason relevant for final
stand against Nix mortis oh wow it's
like last boss holy chef
oh Jesus the site of crisis excited room
which was fun let me know give me [ __ ]
is it going where you going Brock hey
don't run away from me
I was oh [ __ ] creepy oh okay
Isis look around see what Jesus has to
say to us nothing whatever just walking
and during the confessional booth and it
doesn't seem to want me let me into his
particular booth let's go here then Oh
God hey brah hey brah looking back at me
what do you want hey brah
I take it you didn't go oh cool foolish
I rounded ability I'm afraid
nevertheless this is a did allow me the
passage over cards to make contact with
you
well I'm small too smooth you're here Oh
God so why can't three I now almost lost
our God our God our nation save me
you're so damn good can we kiss between
this I know it's like a distance if you
were wondering before I'm cursed with
you or not pretty car I never kissed
anyone between him fine he's dead for me
yes last enough about mankind's fate I
just want a cat's cat
alright I'll make the right choice I'm
Peter Pyle thank do you want for me
all right I'm just gonna what's going on
out
let's go farther I guess can you go in
here all the meters looks like the board
a long time to keep something else it's
not good
should I go back maybe now why would you
want to ruin a game with oh all right
hey what [ __ ] prophesy of Dan one night
I dreamed a little [ __ ] a darkness one
God is gonna be 50 pages again no I can
actually read this a Dalek once dormant
in impatiently waiting was now emerging
from the shadow a light going brighter
from beyond the dark chasm wrapping
around the peerless stained with ancient
penises that's old penises many's Marion
of a shriek and screams engulfed me when
I stood until I felt the burn rise up
from the floor and it consumed me my
soul lived through my shelf was
flattened flattened and became a penis
it became a link between the ancient
world and my reality was amazing a speak
about penises crossed over and began
devouring every living penis and then a
fiend of unspeakable and a mammal of
allah miyan were smiling the penis smile
was amazing as he cross into my world I
know what he means what caused him to
miss well alright he introduced himself
as ancient of the ex mortise for life
that's a pretty cool penis name I mean
I'm still thinking my friend our God
continued
I look at myself tough Adam Balkin man
and stuff all right cool
I don't care can I go back all right
let's count
please let me use tab out god it's gonna
be like a 50-minute thing on God
I love cheating no I never cheat I mean
what come on Jesus tell me what to do
just don't hand there Jesus Christ don't
hang there you know I seen in here or
what can't go what it keeps going like I
don't even know anymore
each pew it's pew really yes I won't
ruin the game Jesus God I see myself and
don't dare to dream about harsh ways I
don't get it
alright can I go or what I don't I don't
understand I don't want to blow in this
game all right okay hey super quick
super take separately separately Oh what
is this
I wouldn't know what is this what is
this what is this what is this what is
their squad alias what this does what
those loves I could find you super good
at cheating how are you going here brah
I bought you something else we can click
here hmm
something else maybe no I don't even
know anymore
[ __ ] this thing keep blinking I don't
understand quite frankly I think I'm
gonna cheat all right
wait where's this mortis there it is all
right after that supposed to click this
door I don't know how I missed the
[ __ ] door but anyway let's go take a
card Oh looky looky running out it's
gonna help it's gonna be on me like a
flash I wouldn't last 30 seconds [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
think both think of course I use this to
fight the ex Marcus makes sense
come on Chad to have is beautiful
Oh God the cards are getting closer a
church over here what is this what is
this oh god he's coming he's coming oh
[ __ ]
all right how do I go back I was just
kidding go back inside big lad got Oh
God
Oh use it is that on there man oh I
don't even come outside with a thing I'm
sorry
oh you look happy oh god he's going here
oh oh oh no ha play again from the start
if she's down man oh no no bro what am I
supposed to do with this I don't I you
just had out and I'm like no I don't
want to make out why didn't everyone
wants to make out on me I don't even
know anymore
ah [ __ ] this little thing only thing is
they're supposed to be
yep I have to keep I just knew that
we're gonna be there for some oh god man
hurry nice girl it's just ripping the
hell out of here
I don't care about ex Lourdes I'm just
gonna go it's pretty [ __ ] dark girl
hey what's going on Savio's legacy I
just ran this is lucky I feel stuck
events for their chance needs me done
what possible significance ice house me
alone nice girl
oh cool falling painting alright that
seems like a very whole part of a man
named smaller because it was a pronoun
I'm saying you need right there alright
like code is usually penis all right
sweet numbers a less difficult alright
yeah
it's conversations why define not
understand all God core toast
[Music]
alright this door first
I'll period everywhere Jesus Christ when
girls more period when will they learn
to control their eyes ever laughs I
[ __ ] alright final go here oh oh oh
[ __ ] you divide by a period everywhere
what about this one can I go ahead I
can't find fun I have to investigate the
period apparently you know that's
[ __ ] great [ __ ] flush toilets and
[ __ ] I'm trying to play there we go
alright this is like the most pleasant
thing so I'm this gonna now there we go
the book of X mortis what I was digging
around in the dusty old self today and I
came across a whole heap of all the bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla that was pretty
cool sorry bran doo doo doo doo doo
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do down down down down down
down down down picking everything oh god
they're children no matter how would it
have to bear witness reality your head
down gentlemen
god damn it I'd have to be Jonah hey
let's burn them I'm just kidding
actually all right let's go
that bloodbath
no American no major oh no oh no
judgment days here I key for me cool no
hope I see about dead so we'll flush the
toilet and I call round
no what are we gonna do with a [ __ ]
lighter in it
let's go down let's go to just go ah
here we go
what is this crawl space it's too dark
oh that's for the light to come chain oh
god I don't like this
oh wait oh my everything i oh no no no I
just shut up
I don't care it shut up alright oh no oh
man I'm [ __ ] got me good
it kept me good real good she was like
hey let's make out and I'm like no I
have a girlfriend
oh oh oh
[Music]
I think that was it for scare games for
me today Ross yeah
like and favorite if you want their a
better [ __ ] left I'm gonna get hard
like one of these days I continue doing
these I swear I make it pretty sweet
video though and you probably get to see
my girlfriend in it anyway hope you
enjoyed and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
come and sleep with me